[Musique]
25 millions de français éligibles au
rappel vaccinal les rendez vous sont
pris d'assaut par les plus de 18 ans au
15 janvier le pass sanitaire sera
conditionnée à cette troisième dose
passe à cette forte demande les centres
de vaccination yvelinois rouvrent leurs
portes
joséphine baker a fait son entrée au
panthéon c'est la sixième femme à y
accéder la cérémonie a lieu mardi à
paris célèbre meneuse de revue mais
aussi résistante l'artiste a résidé au
vésinet elle s'est éteinte en 1975
mercredi 1er décembre marqué la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida le
nombre de dépistages en france a baissé
avec la crise sanitaire - 650 milles en
un an
vingt-quatre mille personnes ignorent
leur séropositivité h et prévention
santé alerte sur les conséquences du
manque d'information des jeunes
notamment
l'antenne locale les petits frères des
pauvres fête ses trente bougies cette
année l'association oeuvre pour les
personnes âgées isolées notamment sur le
territoire de plaisir est les
clayes-sous-bois guyancourt et
villepreux et puis le mois de décembre
marque le coup d'envoi des animations de
noël dans les yvelines et les communes
s'illumine peu à peu et organisent leur
traditionnel marché de noël
[Musique]